unsubscribe very satisfying I am the
artist just filling this thank you very
much
literally it's like shooting yourself in
the face we're working on an urban Zelda
video Garrett's been working on it all
week our friends over at EVIC really
hooked it up this times the the final
pieces to our problem is it in my
Dragunov needs in pretty beasty and
intimidating of a weapon so they so
graciously loaned us this fully
functional airsoft mini guns oh my god
dude it's heavy I would say that's a
good 30 pounds Eva calm we are going to
paint with this today do let's turn the
art world upside down we have two ideas
for what we want to do here
one is a layered canvas so we're gonna
take different colored pieces of paper
and shoot through them also gonna be
taking little bags of paint shooting
them in front of a canvas and seeing how
it splatters Jackson Pollock style onto
the canvas I think you guys need to be
the art judges here the art critics
telling us which design you like best so
stay tuned let's make some art together
you tell us what goes up on the walls
here okay fair enough
shouldn't color what is art
this is what we artistes call the
pairing your method spinning them in the
general area
kind of like you
you're done eyebrow is the Carmichael I
am the artist you can just film this
thank you very much
alright good enough I take back what I
said about putting this up in the studio
he's completely as a gentleman bidding
will start at 1 million dollars you
might use another coat but it kind of
all right looks pretty worn this way
what would you like to know about our
department in front ministry
I started making props in high school
fever maybe even middle school theater
grew up in a fairly small town that
month enough had theater he's kind of
all hands on board and then I went to a
small college theater program there was
similar where you had to learn Tech and
you had to learn along with your acting
suit you could at least have an
appreciation for it and that they just
didn't have the hands for the actors to
not also be labor but it also prepared
me for a real life so when I moved to
New York and was pursuing that side of
my career I found that I got cast in
more roles because I had technical
skills I could light the show make props
for a show help build sets for a show
and then get to be in show so that
that's a very good payoff that have
these technical skills and then that
proceeded to lead to actually working in
film production I didn't go to film
school I knew things because of working
in theatre and just having technical
know-how it's very basic like nothing
I'm doing is incredibly like advanced
[Music]
the prop making it's art and I think of
it like collage almost for this type of
idea where it's like we have pieces for
putting them together we want them to be
interesting the wood it actually was a
standing desk that my neighbor was
throwing away it was by the dumpster of
my apartment building it had this cool
shape which is here now there's a new
dream or this kind of struck me like the
base design of the fairy Navy where she
is kind of a circle with x-4 the wings I
don't know if that will come across but
in my mind that makes a lot of sense
when thinking about being a creative
prop making is very satisfying because
you get to make things filmmaking is
creative collaboration yes you have ah
tours that have a vision and want to see
that vision moved into reality when it
comes to corridor filmmaking this
collaborative working with people who
know can bring that vision into reality
and will have their own input we have
different ideas on what the films gonna
look like when it comes to making props
corridors like you build stuff we want
you on this that makes up do you like
this is sound exciting yes I had my
ideas Adrian has his ideas we talk about
them I make a visual representation like
the gun on the computer it's always good
to have a previz this is v1 looked only
a little bit of gold v2 changes here
final version really only changed
between and then we kind of go back and
forth on stuff this will be the master
rifle this was a little more high
concept so I had an idea and kind of
explained it and then in an earlier step
of this I
Adrian you like this is a direction I'm
moving in that I like do you like this
and he said people loved it when he saw
it so if you want to see how all this
turns out and how the Zelda video looks
subscribe to the corridor crew channel
and you'll find out exactly when it's
coming out now that we've tried the
pairing dirt technique of pointillism I
think it's time that we get a bit more
explosive with this art we've got powder
paint here basically this is the stuff
they use that like the Color Run and I
don't know a bunch of other stuff canvas
first we spray it with some glue and put
the powder in the back we're gonna shoot
the bags powder is gonna explode onto
the canvas I think it's gonna look great
if the bb's dented or break it make it's
not part of the piece that's part of the
heart that's yeah there are no there are
no mistakes no mistakes just happy
accidents Nick are you ready I'm ready
[Applause]
[Music]
so many physicians got hit in the face
like you got any time worked by a
patient did you get hit and get a single
hit literally it's like shooting
yourself in the face it's just tougher
for our little bit of those moody blues
you ready for me to spray going for it
blue
[Music]
oh my god yeah there you go that corner
we're not white go really happy about
this blue flip it like this so that in
the next round of color he'll get the
paint falling this way
Carmichael brings up a good point we
need some yellow and maybe we just
pretty good what do you think of
localizing the yellow to the middle
where the corner yeah actually that's
the under get like down appreciate it
thanks
they do a lot teaching us channel a lot
about all the things that are doing
things that we know do laughter
tutorials on filmmaking itself but we
don't do a lot to toriel on it's
probably the hardest thing in the
filmmaking business which is dealing
with people dealing with people is by
far the most challenging thing about
filmmaking it's actually the hardest
thing about anything whatever job you're
in people are how you get done you need
teams to make things happen what I'm
gonna talk to you about today is
learning how to deal with people
specifically I'm talking about skill
share this before a steel chair is a
online learning website thousands of
tutorials heal making photo media but
not just that but also topics such as
running your business talking to people
entrepreneurship leadership financing
etc and that stuff seems all super
boring but it's not it's actually
probably one of the more interesting
things I have to deal with you guys
watched her interview with Jude there's
a question which is how do you make it
in the film business in this question
applies to any business his answer was
you want people to like you it has a
good advice I was watching some the
classes and when the classes was talking
to people and high-stakes conversations
in other words you're having a
conversation where somebody's livelihood
is at stake
somebody's art is at stake somebody is
really really passionate about something
it's just not that good you need to tell
them this is actually kind of
eye-opening talking about how you to
control your perception of the story
that influences your emotions so you
might see somebody as being lazy it
makes you angry and you want to have a
conversation we just want to yell them
being lazy when in reality you're
constructing a story in your head of
this person being a villain who is being
lazy and not taking the time and putting
it on your shoulders but the reality is
different the reality might be that
they're sick they weren't feeling well
they stayed up all night because their
baby was crying and lots of other things
like that you find it on Skillshare in
fact there's actually a corridor code sk
l dot s H slash corridor crew you get
two free months first five hundred
people that usually will get two free
months we've all seen enough like here's
how use After Effects it's probably time
that we had something else to talk about
like dealing with people that's honestly
one my biggest jobs here at corridors
facilitating need
between everybody also putting lens
protection on the GoPros because that's
like my rule number one dude there's
somebody GoPros tell you we're like out
of cases now I don't have enough
oh there's one Skillshare is generally
more affordable than other online
classes of an annual membership only
coming out to about $10 a month
less than $10 a month actually so you
want to go check it out use the coupon
code Corps accrue to scale that Sh slash
for accrue the first five out of people
that sign up will get the first two
months free and if you guys are tired
tutorials on YouTube that milk that
watch time then skill share will be a
nice change of pace for you yes I hope
you enjoy I hope you learned some things
remember it's not all After Effects
tutorials out there learning to talk to
people is important to the life of an
artist is is extremely emotional can be
very difficult even artist is having a
bad day you gotta respect that
yeah like pain you know in a way what
even when you you paint a canvas you're
shooting yourself with a BB gun
protection bro
to make some magic
pardon
[Applause]
beautiful
we lost all of our blue swaps those
final throttle swaps really polish it
off it's the artist signature
you got a flop on their RV art
now we gotta peel off the table we've
been meeting we're supposed to have like
tying this ago and now we're gonna said
your pony ain't gonna are gonna help
pull this a mommy all right that's
pretty sweet
well I feel like we should just frame it
and put it on the wall you don't even
wait for build a vote on mother okay
you're right you're right what does it
mean to you it means it's next to the
garbage pile which is where it will
eventually go Wow no confidence